let's go now to undata and economics
editor ed conway who is at the sky news
center where he's looking at the big
picture in england and specifically what
could happen at a general election
yeah our team of uh sophologists led by
michael thrasher have been looking
through all of the data four and a half
over four and a half million votes 1 700
wards about 87 councils to work out what
our projection would be
if this were to be extrapolated onto a
westminster vote so we can give you our
sky news projection of what these votes
imply and it is this a hung parliament
with the conservatives the largest party
in parliament if this was applied
extrapolated through to westminster let
me give you these numbers because
they're very important conservatives
with 278
seats so the biggest but not by much
labor on 271
uh seats in parliament the smp on 50.
the lib dems on 28 uh that's kind of an
improvement on before but not quite as
much as some might have uh expected and
then other with 23. what does that mean
all importantly have a look here
the conservatives would be 48 seats
short
of that 326 target they'd need to have a
majority
in the house of commons so that is our
projection sky news projection of what
these results that you're seeing at the
moment imply if this were to be played
out in a westminster election compared
we're looking at the numbers compared
with 2018 and here it is hong parliament
with conservatives the largest party
that is our calculation uh of the
projection uh from these results as
they're coming through